What the $@#% is inflation? We keep
hearing about it, but what actually is it?
Imagine a village that has one market where
people buy all of their stuff, their food,
their clothes. But one day the government
shows up because they're worried about the
economy of this village. So they tell the
people that if they want to take out a loan,
they're going to make sure that the banks will
not charge them a high interest rate. They want to
encourage the people to take out loans and spend
money. Oh, and they also drop off a giant pile of
cash for everyone in the village. And everyone in
the village is like, “Sweet, I'm feeling pretty
rich.” Villagers now are going to their market and
they're buying way more stuff. Many of them have
been eyeing the fancy electric bike in the market
that before they couldn't justify. But now they
totally can because they have all this new money.
The store owner is like, “Sweet, this is great for
business.” But he's running out of bikes. In fact,
he's running out of everything because now all of
these people have extra money and they're buying
way more than they used to. The store owners,
like, “I can't keep up with all this demand.
I should raise prices.” And that is inflation.